[Musique]
le temps des fêtes les trucs
traditionnel ensemble de pain ça nous
irrite les aspics des pains fourrés les
biscuits méritons forme de flocons de
neige même si c'est loin de la cuisine
qu'il propose à son restaurant 20 mon
lapin le chef marc dubié frappier salive
en pensant au menu du temps des fêtes de
sa famille ok oui l'on vient de faire un
retour de retour dans le temps le pain
sandwich texture que c'était mon nom
chronique poser le pain sandwich on le
peut changer on le sait vraiment comme
qu'on le mange à chaque année donc on
est vraiment ici le pain sandwich
tellement d'encre en avril chose on a
tout la grosse en tomate le mix cheez
whiz et de fromage philadelphia qui
évoque la signature du côté de ma mère
on n'était plus dans le fromage
philadelphia et à l'intérieur le
classique les sandwiches au jambon
poulet en étage en attendant ya tout
seul
tout est là alors le buffet de noël
c'est quasiment une compétition c'est là
que la bouffe était la plus colorée que
c'est vrai quand on regarde et table sur
des photos d'époque c'était limite
fluorescentes allemands et explose au
visage
bien installé dans un sous-sol digne des
années 70 l'historien laurent sur coup
nous rappelle comment les kraft de ce
monde
débordé d'imagination à l'époque pour
vendre leurs nouveaux produits
parce que jello et plein d'autres
marques comme spam par exemple vont dire
à l'aménageur parce que c'est à elle
qu'on s'adresse voici comment cuisiner
la chose donc on va produire des livres
de recettes à partir des produits que
l'on achète et l'on va dire aux gens
voici comment impressionner et ça c'est
important
se distinguer avec le peu de choses
qu'on a
[Musique]
à partir des années 40 50
mais il va avoir une industrialisation
de l'alimentation on a développé le tout
pendant la première mais surtout pendant
la deuxième guerre mondiale pour envoyer
de la nourriture facilement mangeable
pour les soldats au front et qu'on va
arriver ici dans les années 50 mais tout
ce qu'on a développés et notamment le
fameux geslot ben envol intégrés dans
les repas noël vous aviez des parfums la
tomate au céleri au café au coca cola et
on pouvait intégrer dans les jello plein
de choses que ça faisait comme une
espèce de pièces montées qu'on présente
les atouts le monde pour dire voilà si
le summum de ce que je peux faire
du milieu des années 40 jusqu'à 1975
c'est l'expansion économique
cette période s'appelle les trente
glorieuses et jean plus d'argent sont
plus nombreux qui veulent montrer qu'ils
sont capables d'en faire plus pis les
couleurs 1 ça marque les imaginaires une
émision couleurs de radio canada y lier
dans les années 50 les années 60 et plus
encore avec l'introduction de la couleur
à la télévision si vous voulez servir un
plat vraiment rafraîchissant essayer
cette aspic de betterave est de chou les
aspects qui on les retrouve à l'époque
médiévale les grands chefs du xviiie
siècle vont cuisiner des oeufs en gelée
bien sûr il faut être très riche pour
avoir justement la gélatine
mais avec la fin du 19e siècle début
xxème siècle le sait général à tout le
monde et l'industrialisation de la
nourriture pas encore plus le
démocratiser
donc certes ça vient des états unis
parce que c'est eux qui vont être le
modèle culturel ce qu'on pourrait
appeler de soft power c'est à dire on
influence mais pas par l'armée par notre
culture la culture américaine la culture
culinaire américaine devient le modèle
type notre jeune chef bien ancré dans
les années 2020 s'est lancé le défi de
faire son premier aspic avis inspiré par
les années 70
c'est le kitsch et de spectaculaire le
jeu de passe et que tout se tient
ensemble c'est quand même la job c'est
pas sa propre aux deux secondes à faire
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'il ya là dedans c'est la
gélatine
enfin content j'ai fait un fonds de
crevettes avec la gélatine
il ya plein d'herbe à l'intérieur puis
du citron qui en dessous c'est vraiment
la mousse de crever être le fait que
encore une fois le fromage philadelphia
la mayonnaise la sauce chili la gélatine
toute blinde et ensemble puis beaucoup
de crevettes évidemment puisque ça c'est
comme l'idée cette part à un étage mais
c'est pas que tout ce que j'avais fait
avant je regardais beaucoup de recettes
c'est quand même impressionnant cette
recette là y'a encore des gens qui
mangent comme à cette époque là dans le
temps des fêtes par souvenez par
nostalgie ou par goût je sais pas oui
parce que ça fait partie du vintage on
veut toujours revenir à nos origines qui
pour certains noël c'est les années 50
les années 60
la nourriture c'est toujours une manière
d'échanger plus encore une manière de
réinterpréter notre pensée
après le pain homme bon et paie sage fr
vous a jamais ça nous un peu sucré le
ministre oui c'est un peu ce crime est
encore une fois la recette si duncan
dessous la sauce hp la sauce coach
sochalien du ketchup
[Musique]
nous c'est très ancrée dans notre
famille on pourra manger ça veut
exactement la même à part ça c'est
vraiment on peut préférer du temps des
fêtes bons souvenirs d'enfance la
diversité des saveurs qu'ont aujourd'hui
elle est loin d'être celle des années 50
qui sincèrement c'est sans doute pour le
mieux parce que si vous prenez une
recette des années 60 puis vous
l'appliquer à la lettre
pour ceux que ça serait super bon mais
ça n'engage que moi ça serait dur de
penser que le goût c'est la première
chose que les gens porter attention
façon simple honneur c'est pas important
mais chip ou parce que selon moi la
présentation peut-être plus importante
que le produit final est ce que vous
avez envie de manger rester quoi on
laisse beaucoup de sport je pense c'est
fait pour rester comme ça
[Rires]
[Musique]